I walk into the apartment,
I open the door,
and immediately a smell hits you.
Now, I can't really describe this smell,
but it's very unpleasant.
So now, I begin to just do your
general just looking around.
Then all of a sudden I'm like,
it looks like the wall is moving.
So, hundreds and hundreds of
roaches on this guy's wall.
That's just when you walk in.
His mattress was completely
infested with roaches.
You could barely see that the mattress,
the color of the mattress.
I'll put it that way. It looked brown.
My name is Larry Bernhardt.
I work for Top Notch Pest Control.
I've been an exterminator
for about 13 years now.
Most pests will reproduce
according to food,
and, unfortunately, New York
is severely overpopulated.
So there's an abundance
of food and shelter
for them to just keep reproducing.
You know, ton of rats.
[Interviewer] Right.
Rodents, roaches, you name it,
it's pretty much in New York.
A few places I would never want to live
is pretty much next to
old, multi-unit buildings.
So like your prewar buildings.
That's basically any
building that was like
built before World War
II in New York City.
There's a bunch of holes in the buildings.
They're not up-to-date regulation-wise.
Old piping, stuff like that,
will always cause pest problems,
a bunch of places for the
rodents and pests to hide.
And, yes, next to a park
because you don't know
what's going on inside of the
park with all the rodents.
Rats tend to burrow, and if
there's a bunch of ground
that they can burrow into,
they're gonna tend to nest there.
Once they start looking for food,
if there's not food ready for them,
they're gonna make their
way into buildings.
Especially in the winter,
they're looking for warmth.
If your building is the
closest to the park,
you're gonna be the
first place that they go.
So the worst floor to live on
would actually be the
ground level or first floor.
Pests generally start
to go from ground up,
especially rodents.
So you'll get your rat
issues and your mouse issues
from the ground up.
The pest problem is
terrible near restaurants.
It really has to do with the garbage,
them disposing of it in the proper ways
and also in, like, a timely manner.
You know, a lot of these restaurants,
they'll just have like a
dumpster out in the back,
and they're just putting
the garbage right there.
What happens is, after nighttime,
the rats are just going to eat.
So as they eat, they'll reproduce more.
And also with these takeout restaurants,
if they are having a pest problem,
and one actually has a roach egg in it,
and now you're putting
it into your cabinet,
yes, you know have an
infestation of roaches.
I think most New Yorkers don't know that
a roach egg will typically
have 30 to 40 babies in it.
So generally somebody sees one roach,
they kill it, and they
kind of move on with life.
They don't realize that the
first thing you should be doing
is calling a professional or at least
trying to take care of it on your own,
that there's probably 30 more
that you're just not seeing.
The most important
things would actually be
taking the trash out every night
and making sure there's no
dirty dishes in the sink.
Also, no clutter.
Clutter is the worst because
once something gets in,
you're not gonna be able to find it
due to all the clutter
and the messy conditions.
You know, we're never gonna be ahead of it
until people start taking
sanitary matters very seriously.
I make my way into the bedroom,
his mattress was completely
infested with roaches.
I've never seen that in all the years
I've been doing pest control.
[Interviewer] What does that mean,
infested with roaches?
You could barely see that the mattress,
the color of the mattress.
I'll put it that way. It looked brown.